uh one of our favorites he's a die-hard
seahawks fan he's the executive producer
and narrator of we are the champions
on netflix which is uh explores
chris i'll read you the liner here okay
explores the quirkiest most charming and
oddly inspirational competitions you
never knew
existed i'm in this week it's cheese
rolling
rain wilson here on the rich island show
how are you rain uh rich i'm doing okay
how are you
i am i'm better for talking to you quite
frankly
it's weird not seeing your face i'm just
hearing your voice
you know what yes that's the way phones
work sometimes
yeah oddly old-fashioned
why why are we not on a zoom call you
know what i think i'm just trying to
break up the monotony for people
everybody's zooming these days you know
just the old-fashioned just pick up the
phone
and give a call but it's good to talk to
you your seahawks look good last night
ryan they looked like they looked okay
there was some redemption
last night they looked okay they got
kind of back into form there was nothing
you know spectacular
but some solid defenses stopped yes i
think
kyler was a little hurt yes i think his
shoulder was a little off so he was not
taking those
you know 20 30 yard bombs down the field
um so um but
uh yeah we'll take it we'll take the
wins well i mean especially defensively
you know um it was tough for your team
to stop anybody
i mean the the bills are still scoring
on them from a couple weeks ago
and so but so to see last night two
three an ounce to start
and then you know murray was off all
night um
you know shoulder is one thing but you
know jamal adams who i had on uh about
an hour ago
uh he's he's a real deal and it looks
like the everybody's beginning to
to gel together ryan uh yeah yeah they
the defense really stepped it up
um some big stuff and they didn't they
just let they didn't let them roam
around the pocket they really like
they've learned enough i think from
scrimmaging with russell wilson on how
to kind of contain a riverback like that
so
um it was good it was solid um
very very happy very happy night last
night in the wilson house
it is weird to see that building empty
of 12s though
it's why it's just really weird you know
yeah yeah
yeah you know i mean because you you
would normally by now you
you had already been to a game or two
right isn't that normally the way you
roll a couple times once
yeah oh yeah absolutely i go i go at
least a couple times a year
yep although they've never asked me to
raise the
flag or ring the spell or what or
throttle that falcon or whatever
people do over there um
yeah i don't know what exactly they do
but i don't
think it is throttling the falcon i
don't think that's what they did well
that's a euphemism for something else
my apology or that could be another it
could be one of the competitions on we
are the champions is what it sounds like
you know that was an excellent segue
thank you sir
you know what i want to leave some time
though rich i want to talk about we are
the champions people are loving it it's
a top 10 show on netflix
but i have to talk about my fantasy
football team to who to start this week
because i'm
really flummoxed okay let's let's take
it one step at a time
let us get to your fantasy football team
first of all what is it called
uh cup my balls
[Laughter]
okay um can i can i ask what the avatar
is
what is the avatar it's just my big
wonderful face
right there it's cup of course k-u-p-p
cooper cup
yes so okay i was proud of that one
all right so uh then i i will say now
that i know
it is uh cup as in cooper cup allowing
me to say
how can i help cup my balls rain
well cooper cup is uh he's a little bit
tough to start these days you know he's
kind of
the second or third option sometimes on
the rams and you never know if they're
going to run it
right so much but they're not passing
i'm
i'm uh i'm a little thick and wide
receivers so we're a half point ppr
okay and we've got two flex spots
oh and i've got cooper copp
justin jefferson boss good for you enjoy
him
leo jones oh my gosh all right and then
i've also got
right now on my bench jacoby myers and t
higgins
oh okay so you need to choose
four out of those five is what you're
saying well it gets more complicated
because then i have
i'm my starting rb is clyde edward
tolaire who is
only okay but then i have duke johnson
against new england he could be thrown
in there too so
i need to choose four of those
six okay jones
i'm gonna start i'm obviously gonna
start julio jones and jefferson no
question
and jefferson it's a must start okay
mustard mustard he's gonna have a big
big day against dallas i'm very
i'm very very bullish on him okay so my
flex then is cooper cup duke johnson
jacoby myers and t higgins
um i think you got to go cup and higgins
don't you think chris that's that's
where i was leaning as well
t higgins for sure the t higgins for
sure and even though
against the washington redskins they
don't i don't know much about the
the i mean the washington football team
i don't know much about their defense or
their corners but
i i would still go with higgins
he's gonna get a dozen targets at least
yes and and even though
cup has not had that big game he hasn't
had that
hundred something yards if it's a half
point ppr you know he's going to be
targeted enough
uh jacoby myers though is
is intriguing to me but i wouldn't
and the beauty of cup too is you've got
um
you've got him in your back pocket for a
monday nighter i don't know why that
would matter anyway we had this
conversation yesterday about how
i had so many players on thursday night
it disturbs me to put so many eggs in a
very first game basket
um even though it doesn't matter the
points all get added up at the end
i just like having somebody from monday
night ryan i always like having somebody
monday night
you know well okay i mean if you get to
tampa bay that's a pretty good defense
i would still i'd still so who are you
leaning towards then
what do you know i was gonna i was gonna
start duke johnson over t higgins that's
the only change i would have made
just because um he's still gonna be the
starting rb
against new england um
that could be a high scoring game so you
might be okay with duke or jacoby myers
in that game
huh all right well you you'll i i
i've given you my i've given you my
thoughts okay i'm gonna go with you i'm
gonna start key higgins i love tee
higgins he's
he's a monster um he's been great
they've got a great chemistry
and um i i'm going to switch it up and
start him and duke johnson is
kind of a putt who else is who else is
in this league with you rayne wilson who
else
this is the office league so this is
brian baumgartner um
who's your good friend john krasinski
um from the cast right we have a lot of
writers and crew members from the office
uh over the years and uh it's been going
for like 12 years
no kidding this is the same league from
when you started when you were shooting
the office um and
and it's still going on strong who is
leading this league
who's winning who's leading this season
yes yes who's winning right now um
anybody that wants uh i guess out of the
ones that we know
uh this um who's
bringing it up um andy buckley
is winning the league he played david
wallace the boss a big boss
over michael okay he's got the most
points and he's in first uh he's in
first place
then uh one of our our our writers
um warren lieberstein is in second
i am in fifth place at six and four
so where's krazynski
tenth place at four and six so in a way
he's in a quiet place is what you're
saying ryan
that's what kristin is nice nice
i'm giving myself a round of applause
yeah okay well he's a direct patriot fan
i know that
and uh bomb gartner's as as packers as
they can come
all right well that's my two cents and
i'm sticking with it but i i
it adds an extra layer of interest for
me for the rest of this weekend here
just
okay i'm rooting i'm rooting for cup my
balls is basically what i'm saying
excellent next what good choice good
choice
can you talk about this show let's yes
are the champion let's talk rayne wilson
here on the rich eisen show you are the
executive producer and also
narrator of this popular streamer uh
this show streaming on netflix we are
the champions i give you the floor on it
we're seeing people enjoying uh going
after rolling cheese
down a hill it looks like great yeah you
know you guys
are gonna love this thing it's six
episodes
of the most obscure and absurd sports
you've ever seen
in your life um including dog dancing
which is my favorite episode this is dog
dancing is huge
in uh in russia uh they it's life or
death
and this is what i love about the show
it's like the sports are absurd but we
take it really really seriously
like it says like this is a life and
death the
thrill of victory the agony of defeat in
these
ridiculous sports the first one like you
mentioned cheese rolling
we've got frog jumping i think we're
seeing hair styling on the screen right
here fantasy hair styling is what we're
seeing on the screen right here
fantasy hair styling yes yes
so um yeah it's just fantastic and um
right now the world is so chaotic and
difficult and
overwhelming and divided but this is
like a show that's just
pure uplifting fun
uh sports themed entertainment so
i really think you can sit down and
watch it with your family
i was about to say my kids would love
this they would absolutely dig this
there's no question about it certainly
dog dancing what is that competition
what is that right you know i don't
know i still don't know i've watched
like four or five cups i don't
i don't understand it but people are
dancing with their dogs okay they're
like
spinning around and their dogs are
spinning around and they're
it's like they're dancing the dog is
dancing it's the
it's the unity it's the harmony between
the dancer and the dog
at their side and um it is uh
it is really hysterical now there's no
is there any performance enhancing drugs
and cheese rolling
you needed to safeguard anything like
that that i
you know we're the we're still waiting
for the results of the urine test on
that one
from the cow right it's the cow you test
the cow do you what do you
the pasteurizing process the
that one in all seriousness is this it's
a
it's they roll a giant wheel of cheese
down the hill and they've done this for
hundreds of years in gloucestershire
england yes
and then you chase the cheese down the
hill no one is ever going to beat the
cheese down the hill because it's a
giant wheel
and people routinely
break bones they have like a sea of
ambulances at the bottom of the hill
and the amount of broken limbs is
staggering and every year these stupid
englishmen get
soused and just tear off down this hill
and they have the men and women's
champions
and um it is is
it's just fantastic you're just gonna
love it and again it's streaming on
netflix you're the
ep you also narrate it and um it's a lot
of fun
um and i i i cannot wait to be a lot of
fun i can't wait to watch it with my
kids they will love it chili eating frog
jumping yo-yo dog dancing
cheese rolling fantastic no wonder no
wonder it's successful
um i asked this of uh brian baumgartner
last time
what are the odds of seeing an office
reunion any way shape or form
ran yeah it's happening um so may 5th
i think we start oh gotcha
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know come on now
i'm up for it but i don't know
we certainly wouldn't have steve you
know john might make an appearance
the our showrunner greg daniels um
god bless his soul i think i don't think
it's i think he would potentially do it
at some point if he found kind of the
right idea or the right way in
but he's not in any rush he's shooting a
couple other tv shows so
maybe someday maybe next couple years
something like that would happen
well um why wouldn't steve want to do it
i mean you know i know he's got a lot
going on you do too
i mean so i mean let's tell it he just
stated that publicly
um because and you know he has no
problem playing michael scott or
anything it's not like oh he's too good
for it he's
such a great kind guy but
he just really feels like we've made a
great show like leave it alone
walk away and um
and he is also like wary about like part
of the show with being you know
politically incorrect and it's really
really hard to be politically incorrect
these days in any way shape or form i
see
i think he's got a good point i would
break it would break records though
there's no question about it there's no
doubt it would break whatever
you know i guess i'll speak on behalf of
peacock i mean at some point that's
you know the series is going to rest
right here on this streamer and
i mean it would br people would go crazy
people do grow crazy any time we talk
office it goes through the roof
i'm sure you see that too whenever you
do that oh sure oh sure and during this
i mean obviously it was just getting
more and more popular
over the years with younger people and
but during the covid you know everyone's
cooped up
watching netflix and they're just
watching the office over and over and
over and over again it's just
it's crazy how popular it's become all
over the world i get messages from like
the office is huge in bangladesh and the
office is huge in
albania and uh so
it's one of those kind of crossover
shows it's really caught fire which is
fantastic i'm so
happy and proud to have been a part of
it you should there's no doubt about it
have you have you did you watch one have
you seen one in the quarantine was the
last time you watched an episode of the
office
uh i watched a handful with my son um
and how's that
yeah how's that go yeah it's okay my
my son is he's 16. okay and he likes the
office
but he he doesn't like being like the
son of dwight
like who's with your dad you know
so he's like he's got a he's got a
he keeps the office at arm's length you
know what i mean he's uh
he he appreciates it but he doesn't want
to kind of get into the whole office
thing but you but
the fact that that that he might not
want to own that is because you were so
good
at the character did you ever explain
that to him ryan
do you need me to explain it to him i
can do that if you need me to like
okay you know like it's not like you are
him but many people just assume that you
are you know what i'm saying
yeah just yeah i'm good for your own
when he was younger he once said to me
he was like
that uh i just want i don't want you to
be dwight i
just want you to be my dad you know gosh
and i was like oh that's so sweet
and i was like shut your mouth little
faker
i have three emmy nominations you little
look at that roof over your head what do
you think bob's there
in great father of the year dreamworld
rainbows
oh man thanks for the call congrats on
we are the champions and good luck to uh
again cut my balls
and um and thank you i'm sorry did you
just
did you just command me to do something
no i didn't i said good luck
too um and i i i hope uh
i hope you know cut my balls brings it
home you know what i mean
i hope it brings home the balls that's
indeed
is that what you call the trophy um
[Music]
that we have a trophy i haven't won in a
while i won a few years back
i don't think they had a pro that's hey
they can never take it away from you
even
whatever it is um we are the champions
available for streaming right now
on netflix thanks for the call rayn you
take care rich great talking to you
yes you got it at ray and wilson on
twitter and instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here